blade Smiths welcome to the forge I'm
sure that you noticed on your anvil in
front of you you have a high quality
Billet of Steel you'll be using that
today but there's a twist today I'm
feeling a little bit
nautical
while forging your signature blade in
your signature style today you will also
have to incorporate an element from the
sea anchor or chain into your Blade's
construction using a sand mine or inlay
technique good luck bladesmiths your 10
minute design window starts
now
I'm going to use a chain it's the right
size and I think I can work and I'm
designing a Buena because it's always
superior cut it's my favorite
I build a knobs to be durable functional
high performance blade is where it's at
I'm going to use a little anchor chain
because the anchors I don't know what
they're made out of I'm just going to go
with a plain Bowie style butcher knife
that's a simple knife to make I feel
really good about this because I'm good
at adapting ideas start flowing and I'm
starting to think okay change something
I can cut straight pieces out of I can
put a handle on it as I'm designing the
blade I am thinking I'm going to go with
something I love to make which is
somewhere between a sex and a sheep's
foot this is my chance to take an
absolute surprise and turn it into
something completely functional maybe
even beautiful if I do a good enough job
the design period is now closed grab
your steel because your three hour Forge
time starts
now
first thing I'd grab the smaller links
the Chain's so heavy really all of us
has got to work together because we've
got to break at least one length before
anybody can have their own
I work with junk iron all the time in my
shop so nothing's the right shape when I
start with it my plan is to take the
wrought iron flatten it out and get two
flat pieces and then sandwich it on both
sides of the W-2 I'm going to get both
my pieces in the fire at the same time
and so when I get one cold I can swap it
out with the old and work it until I
combine them
just trying to turn that crap into
something that looks like a knife
somebody's ain't getting hot
the pcw2 is like 10 inches long and I
want to get the wrought iron draw it out
at least to that length and that width
and the sandwich and Forge weld them all
together
my biggest concern coming into this
challenge is getting a solid forage weld
from wrought iron to this high carbon
steel today's
remember using a power hammer that is so
cool it's so efficient so fast it makes
everything about this a dream come true
okay this message this son of a
now
damn it I realize that I can't get the
wrought iron the perfect size is the W-2
I'm running out of time so I just had to
cut them short
I think we have our first stack
I'm a little nervous welding the W-2 and
the wrought iron together this is
something I've never done why not be the
damn prettiest thing but maybe it'll
work
when I get to wrought iron straight I
cut both pieces and then sandwich it on
both sides of the W-2 and go for a
forged Weld and hope the best there goes
nothing Buster is just cooking that
metal like you wouldn't believe yeah
I got on the power hammer
it's not going real good I made a couple
of Miss licks and got my blade too thin
right in the center and I see an
inclusions and bad places in my blade so
I'm just trying to grind off what I can
it's not working I'm not feeling good at
all about it
my wrought iron and my high carbon steel
they've been drawn out to a sufficient
length
and now it's time to start welding my
Billet together
Rachel is over here she's been at the
welder for a while hopefully everything
comes together real nice Samurai is a
technique I really know very little
about and I really cannot wait to give
this a shot
well that don't look good man
I've seen a cold shut on my blade and I
just went oh my gosh just legs run oh
sometimes you can say sometimes
you can
hope I could pull this off and I said no
you're gonna pull it off stamina there
yeah Sean's eaten of his blade for a
quench
I don't know if the other three were
quenching or not
bail that's how you do it I quenched my
blade but then I pulled my blade out and
I could see just a slight warp but with
time ticking down I feel like I brought
my a game and probably the best that I
could do
I'm noticing that I'm getting bins in my
blade so I'm trying to straighten it out
during the normalizing process which is
not a real good idea
don't hit that anymore please don't hit
that blade anymore come out the second
time on a normalizes crooked again
after straighten it but that's all I got
I didn't run out of time
hey it's now and never I got to dip this
thing
big flame out there you go it's a good
way to lose some beard hair there
do you see that it looks fairly straight
it does when I finally get the belt
sander figured out I am grinding away
and I realized my blade is a little too
long and thin
no
[Music]
but time is flying by it's time to get
my blade quenched
boss this round is over
all right bladesmiths Welcome to our
strength test today is the wooden crate
shop I'm going to take each of your
blades and attempt 10 strikes through
this wooden crate it's going to test the
overall durability of your knife edge
holding and we're going to see not what
your blades can do to this crate but
with a crate can do to your blades
John you're up first you ready yes sir
let's have some fun
[Music]
that's what a chopper should do
just a few little things right in here
in your choil that's sharp I'd like to
see that taken down narrowing down here
would have made a little more
comfortable too swinging something this
big and heavy you want to have as much
control as possible contouring with that
Palm swell in there it's a big help in
holding a wheel in this knife no damage
to the edge or anything nicely done
thank you Rachel you ready I'm ready all
right let's do it
[Music]
wow
oh my God you okay I'm high on life
right now
well Rachel you lost that little flake
there
nothing else seems to have opened up
biggest problem I had with this knife is
the balance there's a lot of weight up
here there's not a lot of knife to
support that tip and whenever I'd strike
on a crate it's actually smashing into
me in the webbing of the hand right
there
your Edge is good though it's still
Sharp
held up nicely good job thank you Buster
how you feeling insecure now
let's do it
[Music]
well Buster we've got a crack going from
spine to Edge right where that thin spot
is how food it was
that is a serious malfunction right
there it's only being held in this
little belly of the clip and if we go to
straighten it for a sharpness test I
feel it's going to break off I
understand I'm sorry but for safety
reasons we're not going to be able to
proceed to the sharpness test with your
knife okay
bladesmiths the tests here in the Forge
are designed to be intentionally brutal
for a reason not every bladesmith makes
a blade that can complete the tests
Buster unfortunately your weapon has
suffered catastrophic blade failure I
have to ask you to please leave the
forge
I'm feeling very disappointed I just
can't prove to myself that I could
compete and that I was better than some
[Music]